I get introduced to Lionel Richie and I
could tell that Lionel Richie doesn't
know me as never heard of me but because
I'm the only other black male at this
event he acts like he knows this is not
happening
I'm rollin with junior when traveling
late
[Music]
the sitting here you see legendary
when I first started doing hip-hop music
even though I'm known for doing music to
has a message a music that is not empty
a music that is not vacuous I grew up
wanting to be a rap star I didn't grow
up wanting to be a conscious rapper I
grew up I wanted to be LL Cool J you
know I wanted to be famous for being a
sexy but by the time my
career took off I was I was on a label
called raucous entertainment and myself
and most def we had a group called black
star right
[Applause]
see I was cheap for applause - nah got
no jokes
I said mos def so y'all could applaud
and black star y'all familiar with that
so bad by the time we blew up the
whole raucous movement the whole
underground movement it was looked at as
the Vanguard for conscious rap like they
looked at us as as bringing back the
sounds of boogie down production of
Public Enemy a rock him and Vic data
came and everything so my homeboys like
I was like 18 19 years old my homeboy
started going to strip clubs and having
fun and doing all the debauchery and
stuff but they didn't even invite me to
the strip club because they heard my
records and they thought quality
wouldn't want to come to strip club with
it and one of my best friends in the
world like he worked he was a bartender
at the strip club when we was like 19 I
didn't find this out - we were like 32
was there cuz they never told me I was
like yo y'all niggas hanging out the
strip club y'all tell me he was like you
you kickin what I conscious rap you
don't want to hang out the strip club so
by the time I got on in the music
business and I started making money in
the music business I really really
really really wanted to go to a strip
club not just a strip club but all the
party saw his partying it down like
anybody who knows me from when I first
started my career you heard my records
and I was conscious rap and I was in the
streets like I don't just talk online on
it's talk on records I go to the rallies
I go to the protest and all that but I
also go to the nightclubs you know there
I also turn up so the first time I ever
went to a strip club in my life I went
with Jermaine Dupri and Janet Jackson
because I was working on a song with
Jermaine Dupri he had an artist at a
sample one of my records
wanted me to be on the remix and
everything a shout out to Jermaine Dupri
but here's my advice if you've never
been to a strip club in your life do not
go with your mane Dupree do not go with
Janet Jackson and make sure you don't go
in Atlanta because if you go to a strip
club with Jermaine Dupri and Janet
Jackson and Atlanta nothing will top
that experience so after
my first trip club experience I tried to
top that strip club experience and
because I was now making rap money I
will start on my career I tried to go to
all the fly strip clubs and the fly
strip clubs in this country are in
Atlanta and in Miami and Portland
surprisingly Portland Oregon ghusl
wallet Oregon is that
but so I was working on my album and I
booked a ticket this story has a lot of
valleys and Peaks so just stay with me I
booked the ticket to Miami because I'm
like I'm going to Miami to turn up so I
get to Miami and I knew some girls who
were some party girls and they do all
the parties and this girl called me she
said come to this party are you in Miami
cuz she I told I was going - she said
yeah she said come to this party I said
where's it at she said it's in the
Bahamas so I was like after some
convincing I went and these girls um
let's just call them um Brittany and
amber they weren't white girls I know
those sound like white girl names but
I'm trying to throw it to set off so
Brittany and Amber they invited me to
this party but they said listen if you
come you gotta follow the rules so I was
like what is this some like eyes wide
shut type so I fly to Bahamas and I
can't I get off and they tell me that I
need to come to the Peter residence now
Peter is like a textile super-rich
billionaire you know San Jose is the
billionaire dude
and so at first when I first get to the
island nobody wants to take me there
they said no one's allowed on the
property I finally convinced a driver to
take me there he dropped me off in front
and I get picked up by one of Peter
it is he comes on a golf cart to the
front of the cage tickets it was all
opulent and decadent like lifestyles of
the rich is famous I felt like I was in
a in Fleming James Bond situation you
know and um the guy picks me up and the
guy who picks me up is asking me about
hip hop and I'm like yeah I rap he's
like yeah I only listen to Frank Sinatra
and so immediately I'm starting to feel
like maybe I'm not in the right place
and there's like spider monkeys I'm
saying spider monkeys because that
sounds official
I don't know what kind of monkeys day
was but there was monkeys you know say
there was peacocks and all types of
wildlife it's like a two day three day
long thing I'm staying in this tree
house and it's beautiful it's beautiful
I've never seen nothing like this and um
I ordered some food and the guy to bring
my food is a Norwegian guy who says to
me you know equality I saw you perform
with black star in Norway back in the
days in the show that he mentioned was
the first time I'd ever been to Norway
as me high-tech most death in some bar
in Norway it was a small bar Oh smaller
than this bar we hit now and it was like
four people in there I remember it was
like four people in this bar and this
kid in the Bahamas is like I saw you
perform at their bar Norway and I'm like
wow okay what are you doing here he's
not been working here for Peter and um
you know I was like okay wow it made me
feel good cuz this is again at the
beginning of my career so then the girls
come and I'm hanging out with the girls
and Britney and amber and all their
friends and it's a bunch of other girls
and they finally explain to me what
what's happening it's like we work for
Peter and because we know all the party
people our job is to invite people here
for parties that he has and this is his
birthday party it's gonna be a huge
party and you're gonna be here for the
next few days it's gonna be fun and I
say okay great
they say one rule you cannot speak to
Peter
cuz they got me up they think I'm
one of them
you're zan but in my mind I'm like I'm
Tyler quali i'ma speak to whoever the
I feel like speaking to when I feel
like speaking so me and the girls have a
big argument because they feel like I'm
about to mess up the whole situation
because I'm just being arrogant about
Who I am and so we're about to have a
dinner and we find out that he's gonna
have a special guest performer for his
birthday party and a special guest
performer is Lionel Richie right dance
on the ceiling Lana Richie life so we
get to the dinner and we're all mingling
about and I had a seat down at the table
with the girls the table was long I'm
all the way down here with the girls I
came with and then Peter his guests are
all the way at the front of the table
and I'm just I'm playing my role playing
a position but Lionel Richie actually
shows up he shows up and I get
introduced to Lionel Richie and I could
tell that Lionel Richie doesn't know me
as never heard of me but because I'm the
only other black male at this event he
acts like he knows me it gives me the
black male brothers salute I get the
whole love like I know Lionel Richie so
now I'm hanging out with Lana Richie and
we still we know similar people in the
music business I start talking to him
and he says come sit with me so now I'm
sitting at the head of the table will
honor Richie and I'm looking at them
girls like see I told you I must speak
one us I'm me I'm not just here with job
I'm here on my own reconnaissance all
right I might be your guest but I'm also
me um so we have this beautiful opulent
wonderful dinner and um you know I'm
always to hook up I'm always to plug I
don't know if y'all know but I smoke pot
and I won't say that I smoked weed with
Lana Richie but after the dinner we were
all hanging out and you know I'm hanging
out with a lot of Richie I put my
hops on the phone a lot of Ricci because
I grew up listening to to the Commodores
you know say what I'm saying like Lana
Ricci is is for for my family was a huge
huge part of my upbringing so Lana rich
he's telling me Commodore story he's
telling me Michael Jackson stories I put
my a father on the phone with Lana
Ritchie and I'm I'm feeling good and and
because Lana Ritchie meeting him
reminded me of my childhood I went back
to my room in the tree house and I would
all these girls and it's like me and
remember was just like the dude whose
party it was Lana Ritchie his wife and
me I'm the only dude dead and it's me
and all these girls and I'm like okay it
is time for rapper adult fun then I'm
gonna have a great time tonight
but we get into this conversation about
family and I'm explaining about how much
it means for me to meet Lana Richie and
I talk about my father and I called my
father and I was so proud that I could
put my father on the phone with one of
his heroes a lot of Richie and what my
kids mean to me and what are the girls I
don't remember it was Britney or amber
one of the girls all of a sudden at that
moment remembered that she had a kid
and she's like you know what I haven't
seen my kid in so long and I'm out here
partying and I'm out here what kid is
she started crying and getting really
upset about the fact that she personally
didn't feel like she was doing enough
for her child and now like the whole
romantic sexual vibe was just no more
adult fun all right so we end up getting
in this whole conversation about the
importance of family and then I went to
sleep so I wake up the next morning I
still supposed to be there another day
but when I wake up the next morning up
to a commotion and I hear yelling and
arguing and I go downstairs and the kid
from Norway the Norwegian kid was
arguing with his boss and the argument
was about the fact that he had told them
that he wanted that day off because it
was his wife's birthday but they told
him that he had to work that day and
he's like you know what you treat me
like you don't take care of me you
don't care about my family you know what
y'all I'm out and the kid quits
right in front of me and in that moment
I think about everything I saw her the
night before and all the decadence and
all that everything that I thought that
I want to be a part of but when I saw
that the only person there that knew who
I was as an artist the only person there
who was invested in me as a person as an
artist he couldn't even stand to be
there no more he was leaving and when he
was leaving something snapped to me and
I'm like you know what as fun as this
looks this is clearly not my scene you
know maybe I need to leave too and I got
in a car with that Norwegian kid and I
went to the airport and I left now I
might have missed out on a lot of fun
you know then but the lesson that I took
from that is your day ones is your a
ones and you should rock with the people
who rock with you and if you find
yourself in a situation where you're
rocking with people who don't really
rock what you find that one person that
rock with you and maybe leave with them
pshaw